former defense secretary Jim mattis is  firing back after President Trump  criticized him during a White House  meeting the president reportedly called  maddest quote the world's most overrated  general earlier this week and said  mattis wasn't quote tough enough on Isis  well last night matt has had some Barb's  ready during his keynote speech at the  Alfred a Smith dinner here in New York  City known for mixing politics and humor  I'm honored to be considered that by by  Donald Trump because he also called  Meryl Streep an overrated actress so I  guess I'm the Meryl Streep of generals  pretty good line Madison also mocked the  president's deferments from service in  Vietnam he said I earned my Spurs on the  battlefield Donald Trump earned his  Spurs in a letter from a doctor great  sense of humor I hope Meryl Streep sends  him a note or something very funny